dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on affair
this paper discusses possible roadmaps
towards building machines that are
endowed with human-like thinking and
before we go into that the first
question would be is there value in
building machines that think like people
do they really need to think like people
isn't it a bit egotistical to say if
they are to become any good at this and
this task they have to think like us and
the answer is well in some cases yes if
you remember deep minds deep queue
learning algorithm it was able to play
on a superhuman level on 29 out of 49
different atari games for instance it
did quite well in breakout but less so
in frostbite and by frostbite I mean not
the game engine but the Atari game from
1983 where we need to hop from ice floe
to ice floe and construct an igloo
however we are not meant to jump around
orbit rarely we can gather these pieces
by jumping on the active ice floes only
and these are shown with white color
have a look at this plot it shows the
score it was able to produce as a
function of game experience in ours as
you can see the original DQM is doing
quite poorly while the extended versions
of the technique can reach a relatively
high score over time this looks really
good
until we look at the x-axis because then
we see that this takes around 460 two
hours in the scores plateau afterwards
well compare that to humans that can do
at least as well or a bit better after a
mere two hours of training so clearly
there are cases where there is an
argument to be made for the usefulness
of human-like AI the paper describes
several possible directions that may
help us achieve this two of them is
understanding intuitive physics and
intuitive psychology even young infants
understand that objects follow smooth
paths and expect liquids to go around
barriers we can try to endow an AI with
similar knowledge by feeding it with
physics simulations and their evolution
over time to get an understanding of
similar phenomena this could be used to
argument already existing neural
networks and give them a better
understanding of the world around us
intuitive psychology is also present in
young infants they can tell people from
objects or distinguish other social and
anti-social agents they can also learn
goal based reasoning quite early this
means that a human who looks at an
experienced player play Frostbite can
easily derive the rules of the game in a
matter of minutes
kind of what we are doing now neural
networks also have a limited
understanding of compositionality and
causality and often perform poorly when
describing the content of images that
contain previously known objects
interacting in novel and seen ways there
are several ways of achieving each of
these elements described in the paper if
we manage to build an AI that is endowed
with these properties it may be able to
think like humans and through
self-improvement
may achieve the kind of intelligence
that we see in all these science-fiction
movies there is lots more in the paper
learning to learn approximate models for
thinking faster model free reinforcement
learning and a nice Q&A section with
responses to common questions and
criticisms it is a great read and is
easy to understand for everyone I
encourage you to have a look at the
video description for the link to it
scientists at google deepmind have also
written a commentary article where they
largely agree with the premise is
described in this paper and add some
thoughts about the importance of
autonomy in building human-like
intelligence both papers are available
in the video description and both are
great reads so make sure to have a look
at them it is really cool that we have
plenty of discussions on potential ways
to create a more general intelligence
that is at least as potent as humans in
a variety of different tasks what a time
to be alive thanks for watching and for
your generous support and I'll see you
next time
[Music]
you